this is a production of Cornell
University
either everyone welcome to the Cornell
turf webinar series this is week six of
our sports turf webinar unfortunately
had some technical issues here trying to
record the first half of this webinar
but we did we were able to capture the
second half so are we guest this week is
dr. chase John Texas A&M University and
so we're gonna pick up the conversation
where him and Frank Rossi are talking
about measuring certain characteristic
to the field soil moisture firmness
traction and they're discussing some of
chases work sampling really in-depth on
a field so hundreds of samples and
getting that out versus you know maybe
only 18 or 20 samples so we're gonna
pick up the conversation there if you
can you know get this data it can be
useful in making decisions
how much do I got a day do I gotta go in
the go mouth should I go by the by where
they stand should I just do a big grid
across the whole field what do you
recommend as far as testing location I
recommend a grid across the field if
you're capable of it some of the
sampling size research that I've done
we've sampled the field all the way down
to 18 samples using a grid across the
field versus 450 samples using a grid
across if you're gonna make a map which
is a lot of what I do then you're gonna
lose some accuracy in your mapping but
as far as the average and as far as the
mean of your field for whatever you're
measuring that typically will not change
based on those sample sizes that we
tested so if your whole objective is to
just identify a mean or an average
across your field you know 18 20 samples
would be good and then you since you're
measuring such few samples in that
instance and you can actually start
looking at the individual data points in
target areas that might look out of
whack
based on those individual values at
specific locations but yeah I recommend
a grid I don't know why some of the
standards aren't agree adjusts oh you
cover the entire field and it kind of
gives you your high in your lows too
right I mean so you have a kind of a
baseline uniformity across your field so
that would be my suggestion so you know
one of the
I'm sure everybody who manages a playing
surface is thinking well this is good
you know but what's actionable well you
know I'm trying to figure out how I act
number one and and number you know to me
it's I don't know it's how much does it
matter because I've seen some of your
where you took what did you take 2000
measurements on one field or something
completely each of that square meter
matter from a safety perspective let's
let's start with the first question
about what's actionable right let's say
you get a shear value that's X okay what
do I do
does that mean something well I
struggled with this question all through
grad school because I'm out here
collecting all this data and you know
what's it for you're right when do we
how do we develop thresholds how do we
know when to do something actionable and
I think this is where it's really
important to tie an athlete's data and
that's when I started incorporating
athletes because you know we're altima
managing the fields for the athletes and
there's no blanket suggestion that I can
say is actionable really because it all
depends on the athletes that use that
field and to go to your point we'll a
small area matter well it depends if
it's a you know an abrupt bare area or a
slight undulation yeah because if the
fleet steps in that then dick you hurt
um there's a whole psychology which I'm
starting to work with sports
psychologists on this stuff on the field
conditions and it's an untapped research
world the field conditions play such a
huge role psychologically on an athlete
I mean I did some work interviewing
athletes as a small-scale study but they
they identify variations in the field
and they adjust their behavior when
they're in those areas and that's a big
deal and that should be justification
enough so going back to the data the
data it's that's why it's so important
to develop your own management plan
based on your own values for your
and then communicating with those who
use your fill on what they want and this
is easier at the professional level or
the collegian level but at the park and
Rec level even kind of creating
thresholds talking with coaches City
League administrators whatnot how they
feel about how the field conditions are
and try to try to base their feedback on
your values and then adjust your
management
it's so interesting because you know
I've actually worked this is gonna sound
crazy I've worked in with the New York
Racing Association at the grass tracks
at Belmont aqueduct and Saratoga and I
made them cut the grass a little lower
to get a denser to see if we could hold
it together better because they would
let it go six seven inches and it would
get thin and wispy and divots would blow
out well as soon as they cut the grass
lower and the horses could see the
imperfections in the ground they went
crazy they were driving the jockeys
crazy because they were it's comfortable
about putting their footing I don't want
to I don't want to like an athlete's the
horses but I think there is some
subconscious value to that I'll tell you
another thing we've learned from working
with our soccer coach here to support
your point about working with your
athletes we get him out there and he
starts kicking the ball around and he
says I like when they can do this and he
takes how they take the ball and then
deflect it and move to the next place
and he goes yeah it's a little the
timings off the ball sticking what now
what I like is what I like is he says
the ball sticking he doesn't say well
you should do this and you should do
that he says because now I don't know
what to do I get really smart guys and
we don't really know exactly what to do
so we're gonna play around we're gonna
test it again get some numbers so we
always get the numbers and then we ask
them how does he like that how does he
like this and then we can say oh when we
use the PGR the sand and the mower like
this
he likes that or when we roll three
times a week like we're rolling before a
game and trying to wet before a game at
the high levels of course right that you
can do that but it does speak to that
sort of the value of that communication
let me ask you about
divits because one of the things about
grass fields certainly I hear from Andy
and John about synthetics is that you
don't give it right the foot sticks and
and they can perform better it tends to
be why I think a lot of them like
performing on synthetic turf sometimes
how much there's a little vivid like
that matter is you're suggesting if they
see it they adjust how they play well
you know a little divot maybe not but
you know if some of these highly used
recreational level fields that have you
know square yard of bare thin turf that
that will that could affect them I mean
we I go back to Georgia and our
recreational fields we had a sprayer
mishap where the spray boom got turned
on and basically just killed a strip of
grass and it was right in the middle of
the rugby goal and it was a little thin
you know no more than a foot wide but it
was maybe you know six feet long and
that affected the players all season
long because that was the field I was
doing my research on and I was talking
to the players back and forth whenever
they were in that area over time they
knew it was there they weren't looking
at it but they knew subconsciously it
was there and that affected the way that
they moved in that area because they
were waiting to have some kind of
misstep in that area yeah so serious can
affect I think yeah so here is the work
you're doing now can you see my screen
yes yeah here's the work you're doing
now you want to take a minute and
describe what this is what's involved
with this research because it looks like
a heat map does it mean there's a lot of
people where these red spots are and boy
is this suggesting you'd and here's the
gold mouth back here talk a little bit
about this this looks really cool so
this is uh so this device that device is
a GPS athlete's tracking unit the
athletes these are becoming really
common I think this is going to be the
future well it's already here at least
in athlete data analytics from from a
performance standpoint a lot of the
professional teams already we're on
college is already where they're
relatively affordable I would assume
they're going to start trickling down
even into high school maybe
here relatively soon clubs were bursting
around but they the athletes essentially
are wearing a vest with a pocket in the
back neck and this little device is
about a inch wide three inches tall and
it just slides into a pocket in the back
and they wear them throughout the game
and it has an accelerometer in there as
well as a GPS so it's MIT it's measuring
every where they go in the field the
time spent in the field it's measuring
acceleration deceleration all of these
different performance variables and one
thing one thing I always wanted to look
at and I was looking at in the study
actually is how can we tie this data
that's already being collected I mean
all these teams are already collecting
all of this performance data how can we
start making these connections to the
field and how that's influencing their
performance another thing with these
softwares with the GPS athlete tracker
software's is they have surveys attached
to them so before each practice or game
they're asking athletes their soreness
they're able to pinpoint specific
locations on their body where they're
sore where they're hurt there's post
surveys how hard did they feel like they
how much energy did they feel like they
exerted how much sleep do they get the
night before you know there's all these
different variables that can be tied
together and they're doing all that over
on the sports science side of things or
the athletic training side of things why
can't we tie our field data into it one
thing that always drives me nuts and
anybody who's ever heard me do a
presentation is this whole concept of
field playability and safety we throw
that word around all the time what does
that mean
like what does it mean well I know it
means here's what I know it means I know
if the fields too hard somebody's heads
gonna crack open and if the traction is
in some value some guys who played
around with this tell me maybe that's
riskier that's what I can tell you
safety is that's as good as I can tell
you yeah so we have data now we can
collect we can collect the data and for
a specific field with a specific team
even down to the individual athletes
because sports trainers have individual
athlete profiles where they're their
targets they're following each player's
data we can get it down to this specific
player what is a safe environment for
each player
what what's a safe environment for each
team we can start connecting that with
our team if we manage you know we're
obviously talking to our local filter
but we can start manipulating field
conditions to suit an athlete or a team
and so that leads me to my last question
before we see if anyone else has them is
this is really cool and I've you know
loved sort of it the research and how
we're progressing but it sounds like
fundamental to this is a conversation
with the users of your field now this is
not has always been a strong point for
our sports turf managers right and it
wasn't it's not always a strength of
anybody in the turf business that we're
excellent communicators so how you know
in how you're doing this and maybe the
way you're approaching it in Texas when
you when you visit all those Friday
night light places you know it's high
school football it's still 20,000 people
showing up for high school football game
in Texas but I don't know if they're
doing the athlete tracking that would be
absolutely crazy to me they probably are
at some level but really see if we can
find let's see if we can find a lower
level how do you start this conversation
with coaches and communities where where
do you see this starting because it
seems to me some somebody's got to reach
out to the athletes because the athletes
aren't gonna come to us unless there's a
complaint what are what do we say to
start that conversation with the people
who use our field well I think it's a
basic introduction team staff or team
coach and say you know look man we
manage this build to a high level we
expect we have high expectations for it
and we can we can adjust the way that we
do things around here based on your AWS
needs and just open up the conversation
that way and ask what they expect don't
assume what they expect based on what
you you expect no but ask what the team
expects from the building and what you
can do to help meet that expectation
perfect perfect ending Carl that's how
about some questions any questions no
questions so far
you know I think everybody's just kind
of anion I am - just how much data we
can collect especially this athlete
stuff now that you can put a tracker in
and
and and it's funny that the sports
science side is so far ahead there and
then on the turf side you say hey why
don't you give us a little bit of that
and and we can make some some use of
that too so no questions for now sorry I
jumped off there a little bit but at
least we'll have that most of the
conversation with chase recorded yeah
and let me just follow up chase what do
you think about our site-specific
cultivation thing is are you seeing
people doing that is you know as
everybody's got reduced staff obviously
we even without testing you know where
you got some hard spots do you recommend
that or is that really messing up the
uniformity of the field too much I'm a
little worried I'm hoping I didn't
create a problem here well yeah that's a
good point because you don't want to
overdo it that's an area of research
that I want to go towards that's kind of
the next step from a management
standpoint of how can we use some of
these soil moisture maps or you know
like you said you don't even need a map
maybe to do some kind of site specific
era fication but does that work and does
it actually improve uniformity long term
how does it improve the longevity of the
field so those are questions I think
that need to be investigated a little
bit more but yeah I mean I think it's a
good start it makes sense right
if you verify the hardest part is your
field and let the other parts and it
should improve uniformity but we just
don't know that well here's what we know
it did I know it it's it softened it and
it put it in that range now if if I
start measuring across the field and if
you can see this slide you see what I'm
talking about as I start measuring
across the field I can see where my
hardness is and target that and
hopefully bring it in line at least with
the area around it but you know part of
what I'm trying to understand is the
resolution you know I don't want guys to
dismiss that there to do this chase
because it's like it's gonna take too
much time maybe you just start where you
know hey you got a square meter of bare
ground why don't you start there right
are your goldmouth you don't need to
test that there's no grass there raise
it up
top tray
those sorts of things you don't
necessarily need a to get started but
data I think helps with the it gives us
a shared language with the athletes and
the coaches and the play and our
administrators right and yeah I don't
want to switch gears to golf but I did a
study in Minnesota where we interviewed
golf course superintendents on their
knowledge of the variability within
their fairways with respect to moisture
for irrigation and I think like eleven
out of the twelve new you know they knew
their dry spots and their wet spots
across their fairways you you don't need
you don't necessarily need data for
everything the value of having the data
those you have a number to create the
threshold to communicate like Frank said
but to do an action to do some kind of
action like era fication or irrigation
you know you know most of the time
managers will know their areas and yes
that's definitely a good starting point
hundred percent 100 percent well chase
Carl how we doing we got the 30 minutes
we're still the fastest 30 minutes and
turf brother that's right that's right
I think that's a good stopping point
again thanks thanks chase for coming on
that's uh you know I dropped out there
for a little bit but it is really
fascinating to see how these sorts of
data sources are allowing us to survey
their car yes so let me take it and ask
how this is working out because I gotta
tell you chase I'm loving these
conversations I got some rockin I got
you I got McNish we got raucous wah
there's a lot of people out there you're
the next generation of course you and
Gerald have led the way you know in the
sports turf area I think the early guys
were saying and if you ask me knit study
and the athlete's changed things for
everybody the the connection between
those things and you know Johnson rockin
who works for the Players Association in
the NFL you know they're talking about
adjusting contracts because of playing
on synthetic turf over a long period of
time so Carl what do we got for the
survey there yeah I just put it in the
chat box for everybody so uh feel free
to go in there it's an anonymous survey
just stay asked and some questions on on
these webinars the information in here
and kind of how you get into the to the
webinar so trying to demonstrate some in
so that we can continue to get support
for the program this has raised the
profile a little bit which has been
really nice during these difficult times
and we're so grateful to my colleagues
like Chase for joining me and you know
if I have anything to say I would get
invited but I'm just a good one at
asking questions so I'll just stay up
here and hopefully you'll respond in the
Qualtrics survey and tell us how this is
working out for you how much you like it
demonstrate our impact and even if
you're watching the recording use the
link and give us that feedback it's
really valuable to help us do this and I
know chase as a young extension faculty
having this measurable impact having
this measurable impact and we'll send
you some of the notes we get so you can
put it in your reappointment package
sound good all right thanks for joining
us take care everyone
thanks a lot call thanks everybody
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu